[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN: Hey, developers.
Welcome to the G Suite Dev Show.
I'm Wesley Chun.
Before we get started,
I'm excited to announce
you'll be seeing more of my
colleagues in future episodes
as our team has grown,
and I'm looking forward
to learning from them.
Now, what will I be doing?
In addition to G Suite, I'll be
spending more time on the Cloud
Platform side of the house.
As such, I thought it would
be fitting to combine features
from G Suite as well as GCP.
Before we get started,
you know how sometimes,
when you get something done, you
stop as soon as it's working?
Take these stairs here.
We could quit now
because it works, right?
Well, I'm here to argue that if
you just finish the rest of it,
it'll look more
appealing visually.
And that's the theme for today's
show, completing that last mile
and literally making
things more presentable.
We're going to walk through an
App Script app that takes you
from big data analysis
with BigQuery,
all the way to a Google
Slides presentation,
leveraging Google
Sheets in between.
We'll link you to the
code LEP at the end
so you can build it yourself.
Now, the motivation
for this app?
I was inspired by three samples
our team has already created.
First is the Apps Script
BigQuery sample in our docs.
Second is the sample app
in the generating slides
from spreadsheet data video.
And finally, the third was
the Google Slides API code lab
app, which uses BigQuery to
analyze open source license
data.
Now, first thing.
What's Apps Script?
Well, it's a customized
JavaScript serverless runtime
for G Suite automation,
extension, and integration.
More importantly, how do
you access Google and other
services with it?
Well, at this time,
there are two ways--
built-in and advanced services.
A built-in service is one in
which a native Apps Script
object provides
API functionality.
In our app, we'll use
both the Google Sheets
and Slides built-in services.
And advanced services, where
there is no native Apps Script
object to use.
Instead, these rely on
the HTTP-based REST APIs,
meaning an advance
service is just
a thin wrapper around that API.
Our use of BigQuery
is exactly that.
There is no BigQuery
service, but there
is an API and an advanced
service that uses it.
In some cases, such as
for Sheets and Slides,
both built-in and
advanced services exist.
So which do you pick?
Well, generally, APIs
operate at a lower level.
So a built-in service may
not have all API features.
On the other hand,
built-in services
operate at a higher level,
and often, a built-in service
function is easier to
use, that would otherwise
require multiple advanced
service or API calls.
Now that we got
that squared away,
let's begin with BigQuery,
GCP's big data analysis tool.
I mentioned I was inspired
by our Apps Script BigQuery
sample.
Well, it's an app that finds
the top 300 long words, which
means longer than 10 characters,
in Shakespeare's works.
It's a cool query, but I'm just
interested in the top 10 most
common words in Shakespeare.
So let's switch to
this query instead.
All right, we're going
to dive into the code,
and you'll see where
the query comes in.
At the top, we set
the name of the query,
which will also be the name of
the spreadsheet and slide deck.
Next is a project ID, which
is required by BigQuery.
After you create your project
in the developer's console,
click on the Settings
three-dot menu
that you see up in the
corner next to your avatar.
Select Project
settings, and then copy
that project ID string to
the project ID variable
you see in the code.
The "if" statement is there to
stop you if you don't have this
set.
The only function in this
first version is runQuery.
It starts with the query
that we picked earlier.
The last few lines kick
off the job in BigQuery.
And the job ID is used to
help collate the results.
Now, the next section of
code waits for BigQuery
to finish using the
exponential backoff technique,
awaiting a bit longer if
results aren't in yet.
Well, the results are ready
once the job complete flag
goes true.
Now it's time to fetch all
that data from BigQuery,
appending chunks of page
at a time, or flag an error
in the logs if
nothing comes back.
At this point, we're
holding onto a lot of data,
so you need somewhere to put it.
Now, you could display it to
the screen or put in a database
and be done with it.
But to promote G Suite with
GCP and to make it more visual,
it's better to put
in a sheet, right?
Well, in this part
of the code, we
create a new sheet
with the query name
and then add the first
row headers, first
converting them to uppercase.
The results from BigQuery
isn't formatted in a way
where we can just push
it directly into a sheet.
Instead, we need to put the data
into a more normal 2D array.
By the way, massaging
the data into a format
your app can better
process is generally
referred to as ETL,
which stands for extract,
transform, and load.
Once the data has been
added to the 2D array,
we can put those
values into the sheet.
Got to start at
row two so we don't
overwrite our headers, right?
OK.
So now that our data
is in a sheet, cool!
Now I know what the most common
words in Shakespeare are,
and I didn't need to
count them up myself.
Certainly better than being
in a database somewhere.
Now, it looks great,
but it would even
be more cool if we
could visualize it
just a tiny bit more,
say with a chart.
OK.
Here's the new function that
we'll create for our chart.
It takes a spreadsheet object
and creates a columnar chart
based on the data in
cell range A2 to B11.
It then inserts
the chart starting
on row 5, column 5, which is E.
Now, one tweak we need to make
is to return the
spreadsheet from runQuery.
So we need to add this
as the last line there.
Now the last step is to
create a new driver app that
calls both of these functions.
The first to query and return
the newly created sheet,
and then to add a chart to
it by passing it to create
column chart.
When you run the
modified app, you
get the data, plus
this cool chart!
Much more visually
appealing, right?
Now you have an idea of how
the Google Sheets and its API
reduces manual labor.
By bringing in some
automation, you
can make better
use of your time.
OK, next step.
Now you could send
this to management,
but can I make the result
even more presentable?
Like with a presentation?
Well, the answer is yes.
So we'll use the Slides
built-in service to do that.
Let's create a third function
that takes a Sheet and Chart
objects and creates
a new slide deck,
filling in the title and
subtitle on the default title
slide that you get with
all new presentations.
Now, add a blank slide
for the spreadsheet data.
Much like how we copied the
resulting data from BigQuery
into Sheets, we
need to do something
similar to get that data
from Sheets into Slides.
And don't forget the headers.
The code you see here reads
all of the data from the sheet,
creates a new table
on the new slide,
and then writes all
that data into it.
Now, let's add one
more blank slide,
then insert the
spreadsheet chart into it.
Pretty straightforward.
The final step is to update our
driver app to call all three
of these utility functions.
Don't forget to
update Create Column
Chart from the previous
step to return the charts,
so we could pass it to
Create Slide Presentation.
Now check out the beautiful
slide deck we have here.
You've now completed
that final mile,
going from big data analysis
all the way to a slide
that you can deliver
to management.
And best of all,
without spinning up
any server resources yourself.
The goal today was to
show that you've already
done the 80% hard
work, but the last 20%
is to put frosting on your cake.
So what's next?
Well, there's many
directions for you to go.
To build this app yourself
and to see all the code,
we invite you to do the Code Lab
and take a look at our GitHub
repo.
This app was featured
in our serverless talk
at the 2018 Cloud
Next conference.
Check out the talk to find out
more about interoperability
between GCP and G Suite.
Hint, in the near future, you
won't need the BigQuery advance
service anymore, as there
is now a BigQuery connector
feature in Sheets.
Also announced at
Cloud Next, you
can edit your BigQuery
query directly from Sheets.
Cool, right?
And that's it for now.
You've done the
hard work already,
but need to justify
your work to management.
So we hope the
sample app inspires
you to code that final mile
in all of your projects,
with GCP and G Suite dev tools.
This is Wesley Chun, and we'll
see you upstairs in the suite.
[MUSIC PLAYING]